(soft music)
- [Narrator] When you
live in the Swiss Alps,
you have to account for the mountains.
Hence, the cable car.
Life here has forced
residents to get creative
with how they get around.
Here in the cantons of
Obwalden and Nidwalden,
the cable car tradition dates back to
the beginning of the 20th century.
It's no wonder then that the region boasts
one of the highest
concentrations of cable cars
in the whole world.
- [Koni] We have small ones,
big ones and (speaking foreign language).
Then we have also chairlifts.
- [Narrator] Koni here is responsible
for monitoring an
intricate web of cable cars
that, despite looking new, has been in place
since the 1920s.
It can get riders to vistas like this.
- [Koni] In the morning, we have to start
a cable car down in Engelberg at 6:45.
We have to be focused the whole day
to see everything that's happened.
- [Narrator] And while for
some, cable cars are just
a means to reach the mountaintop,
for others, they're private
lifts to their homes.
- Hello.
(Ueli whoops)
- [Narrator] That's right,
this man has his own cable car.
His name is Stanton.
This champion.
- [Narrator] And if you
want to ride in Ueli's
cable car, well, you're
on your own, literally.
It's a self-steer operation.
- My home, Swiss land
mountain farmer here,
very, very good.
(theme music)